mind your decisions I'm a presto Walker
in a semi-circle draw a chord with a
length of six draw another chord with a
length of six and a third chord with a
length of 14 the question is to solve
for the radius of the semicircle I
adapted this problem from a tweet by
Bilal Saddam Ashley pause if you'd like
to give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this problem
[Music]
we'll get started by drawing a cord to
connect the two cords that have a length
of six because these two cords have
equal lengths the angles opposite them
will have equal measure
therefore the arcs that correspond to
these inscribed angles will also have
the same measure
now draw this cord of the semicircle the
inscribed angles will correspond to
equal arcs and therefore they will have
equal measure equal to theta next the
semicircle will have a diameter of two
times its radius an inscribed angle in a
semicircle will have a ninety degree
measure and be a right angle therefore
sine of theta will be equal to 6 over 2r
we'll draw another chord this is also an
inscribed angle of the semicircle
therefore it's a right angle
consequently cosine of two theta will be
equal to 14 over 2r we can now focus on
these two equations cosine of two theta
will be equal to one minus two times the
sine squared of theta and we can get
sine squared of theta from the second
equation we also multiply the second
equation by two and then we can
substitute into the first equation we
now multiply both sides by two R squared
and then simplify this quadratic
equation since the radius has to be
greater than zero we get the solution
that R is equal to nine and that's the
answer to this problem I love how this
seemingly simple geometry problem leads
to a quadratic equation and a fittingly
nice answer thanks for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]